[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
mistake to stock price by the way a bud
light's parent company is now cratered
in recent days as the backlash grows and
grows and grows over the brand
partnering with a trans Tick Tock quote
influencer one industry expert is now
telling the New York Post that the
boycott is stronger than uh most that he
has seen and could continue to hit Bud
Light and Anheuser-Busch hard and it's
not just Bud Light even some actual
female athletes are now speaking out in
support of allowing biological men into
women's sports others though are
thankfully standing up for sanity
particularly those that have actually
had to compete against biological men
former College swimmer Riley Gaines is
one of them but here's what happened
when she tried to tell her story at San
Francisco State recently take a look at
this
[Applause]
joining us now is former NCAA incredible
swimmer spokesperson for the Independent
Women's Forum Riley Gaines is here
well thank you Sean I appreciate it
12-time All-American former University
Kentucky student athlete five SEC titles
uh but then you got forced to share a
locker room and compete against Leah
Thomas in the 2022 NCAA Women's swimming
Championship uh you tied her within a
hundredth of a second but why'd they
give the trophy to her
well I asked you know why are you giving
the trophy to Thomas and they said to me
well Thomas has to have the trophy for
photo purposes you can pose with this
one but you'll give it home or you'll
give it back you go home empty-handed
Leah takes the trophy home yeah so both
my kids have been division one athletes
and I'm very proud of them they weren't
they worked at their Sports from the
time they were seven and my sisters were
swimmers how many hours did you prepare
to get to this level of success in your
career because you have an astounding
record of success
I started swimming when I was four and
I'm 22 now so I dedicated 18 years of my
life to achieving maximum performance in
my Sport and at the Collegiate level you
practice six hours in the water every
single day three of those hours being
before 8 A.M
um so it's impossible to put into words
the amount of time and the sacrifices
that you make to compete at that level
you're a phenomenal athlete so you
recently made an appearance at San
Francisco State University and it didn't
go well not on your part but because of
the heckling and you know apparently uh
you were under you were threatened
police had to come to your rescue you
you were put in a room for some three
hours tell us about what happened there
so I was invited there to speak
um I went I delivered a speech there of
course was lots of protesters in the
room which I'm totally cool with I
welcome people with differing views than
me I encourage it actually I encourage
their questions I answered their
questions but after this speech I was
met with an ambush people from outside
the room they stormed in they turned the
lights off they rushed me they
physically assaulted myself and others
in the room a police she helped evacuate
me from the situation to which we went
in the hallway where we were only met
with more protesters that's where you
saw the video and that's when I was
barricaded in that room along that
hallway for three hours they demanded
money for me if I wanted to make it home
safely to which the dean of students
negotiated with them and I'm sitting
there listening you know how are we
negotiating my safe passage home I
missed my flight they were yelling
terrible violent obscene awful vengeful
things at both myself and the officers
who were protecting me and it was was a
traumatic experience I of course was
prepared for protesters but there's no
way you can prepare for something like
this an ambush a violent Ambush I'm so
sorry you went through that I really am
then you had the president of the
student body at the school saying as the
president I condemn and stand against
the hateful rhetoric and promotion of
violence spread by turning point USA and
you Riley Gaines as well as the
confrontational Behavior at the behest
of the campus Administration excuse me
you worked your whole life to become a
top athlete and whether people want to
admit it or not you know you know who
agrees with you somebody that I'm
friends with Caitlyn Jenner I knew
Caitlyn Jenner for years I knew Caitlyn
Jenner when Caitlyn was Bruce Jenner and
we've spoken often about this topic and
the way she says it is I don't care
about somebody's hormone levels at 18 19
or 20 what were they at puberty because
that's where the difference is made so
it is clearly biologically an unfair
Advantage do you think ultimately your
side wins this debate for the sake of
women's sports
a hundred percent it has to right
because we're backed by science we're
backed by Logic and reason quite frankly
Common Sense the other side they don't
have that to persuade their argument and
that's what was why it resulted in the
way it did at San Francisco State they
have to resort to violence because they
have no other way to persuade you not
only are you an amazing athlete uh you
are an articulate powerful spokesperson
for common sense that has an enormous
amount of Courage uh was so gratefully
came on the program we hope you'll come
back Riley thank you so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else